the sentencing of former USA Gymnastics
dr. Larry Nasser will take place next
week so more of his sexual abuse victims
can give statements about 70 have
addressed the court so far more than a
hundred women signed up to speak minutes
ago in the courtroom 2012 Olympic team
gold medalist Jordyn Wieber denounced
Nasser and officials from USA Gymnastics
our bodies were all hanging by a thread
when we were in London who was the
doctor that USAG sent keep us healthy
and help us get through the doctor that
was our abuser the doctor that is a
child molester dr. Jon LaPook spoke with
four of Nasser's victims he's at the
courthouse in Lansing Michigan
with that part of the story John good
morning good morning Larry Nasser is
already serving 60 years in prison for
other charges and faces now at least 25
more years after pleading guilty to
sexual abuse the disgraced former doctor
claims his health is suffering from
listening to dozens of women at his
sentencing hearing that complaint did
not sit well with the judge I have to
say this isn't worth the paper it's
written on judge Rosemarie Aquilino
received Larry Nasser's complaints in a
single space letter that was six pages
long
in it he wrote now aqua lena is having a
four day sentencing media circus Akulina
said if I pass out she'll have the EMTs
revive me and then prop me up in the
witness box says that the animals like a
cathartic the judge did not hold back
you spent thousands of hours
perpetrating criminal sexual conduct on
minors spending four or five days
listening to them is significantly minor
considering the hours of pleasure you
had at their expense and ruining their
lives among the survivors who spoke
thursday jamie dancer a gymnast on the
2000 olympic team all you get to look
forward to now is rotting in prison for
the rest of your life Olympic gold
medalist Makayla maroney's written
statement was read in court he abused my
trust he abused my body
and he left scars on my psyche that may
never go away
so many brave women got up there and
said you can know my name now Lindsey
Lemke and Tiffany Thomas Lopez gave
impact statement this week Larisa Boyce
and Sterling wreath men are still
waiting for their turn
he thought he was stronger than us and
had control over us and now we have the
control over him and that's exactly what
he showed and he couldn't handle it
the survivors I spoke with said they
felt empowered hearing each other
statements in court but clearly there's
still a lot of healing left to do USA
Gymnastics is abandoning the National
Team Training Center at the karoli ranch
in Texas several of NASA's victims
called for that move because they had
been abused there John thanks